as the only authorized manufacturers
have left is tears tumblers in the world
I think it is important that we finally
stand up here at the Daily wire and do
our environmental duty to help save the
planet with an important public service
announcement when you're drinking salty
and delicious leftist tears from our
tumblr please be sure always to use a
plastic straw maybe use two of them for
one it will prevent the salty tears from
staining your teeth and that's very
important but two it will help to save
the planet and shrink the non-existent
garbage island in the Pacific Ocean
while polar bears don't starve in the
Arctic fracking doesn't poison water
wells and electric cars kill people we
will analyze everything you know that
just ain't so about mankind's impact on
our natural environment then the Griffin
family stops by to discuss giving birth
to a baby in a chick-fil-a restaurant in
Texas on this is America that is the
most America I'm gonna have to cancel
this segment afterward finally the
celebrity is gunning to take down
President Trump in 2018 and beyond
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you know when I was doing that setup I
probably should have had a straw left
this tears tumblr now my teeth are gonna
be all stained and I won't be saving the
environment we have a lot to get to
today this is a lot of really lot of
good stuff to cover before I get on my
plane before that though I have got to
thank a new phenomenal sponsor purple
mattress now you might have seen I was
on Fox and Friends this morning at the
earliest possible time in on earth so I
didn't get to sleep a lot when I do get
to sleep though
purple mattress is the way to go baby
purple mattress is so so good if you're
struggling to get a good night's sleep
you've got to try a purple mattress it
is it will certainly make you feel
different than anything you've ever
experienced because it uses this
brand-new material that was developed by
an actual rocket scientist looking I'm a
man of simple tastes I'm easily
satisfied by the best and I need my
tumblers to be designed by the genius as
a daily wire and I need my mattress is
made by rocket scientists they are it's
unbelievable it's unique because it's
both firm and soft at the same time so
it keeps everything supported well still
feeling really comfortable plus it's
breathable so it keeps it cool it ends
up giving you this zero-gravity like
feel so it works for any sleeping
position you get a hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not satisfied
you get a full refund 10-year warranty
free shipping and returns free in-home
setup and old mattress removal what do
you want you want to make you sandwich -
this is a great deal folks you're gonna
love purple and right now my listeners
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress go there right
now purple comm promo code cough FA Co V
Fe Fe do it I'll wait I'm waiting I'm
waiting purple comm promo code cough FA
Co V Fe Fe the only way to get this free
pillow is to use cough FA a checkup
purple comm promo code Kofi Fae okay so
this is terrific you know that for the
last two weeks now so the straws have
dominated the headlines
Starbucks is getting rid of its plastic
straws now they're going to infantilizes
and use those little sippy cup things
nobody can use straws I think by the
latest statistic from the seven-year-old
who did a survey is that seven zillion
straws are used every day killing the
environment killing the polar bears ID
all this stuff right you know all that
not true it turns out that banning
plastic straws is bad for the
environment right now
Starbucks is still going to be
instituting this I love these kinds of
stories I love the stories where the
really earnest environmentalist the
preening types get proven totally wrong
because the they might have good
intentions but the road to hell is paved
with good intentions why is this why is
banning plastic straws bad for the
environment well there are different
types of plastic number one number two
number three and in particular we should
focus on number two and number five
number five is polypropylene
and number two is high-density
polyethylene straws are made plastic
straws the kind you get at the coffee
shop are made from number two into
number five plastic and number two is
pretty easy to recycle number five is
very hard to recycle only three percent
of number five plastic is recycled so
97% of number five plastic we send it to
China to recycle it China doesn't
recycle it it ends up in the ocean
somewhere so the straws that they're
using could be number two could be
number five those lids those sippy cup
lids are much thicker in there number
five so they're replacing the straws
with these thicker lids and the thicker
lids are virtually impossible to recycle
so it actually will create a greater
negative environmental impact this whole
straw thing I don't think we've covered
this enough and it's not totally common
knowledge you might be wondering why you
woke up one day and all of a sudden
plastic straws were public enemy number
one you might say it's because we live
in an utterly decadent culture with no
actual problems so we just have to
invent them for ourselves that's also
true the other reason is that there's
this nine-year-old boy named Milo kress
nine years old in 2011 seven years ago
and he decided that there were too many
straws like a nine-year-old does for a
nine year olds make these kind of stupid
observations and extrapolate from there
so this number 500 million straws
consumed daily America uses 500 million
straws daily this has been reported in
the New York Times it's been reported in
USA Today it's been reported in National
Geographic it's been reported by the
National Park Service the trouble with
it is it's plucked out of thin air the
there was a nine-year-old who thought
there were too many straws Milo cress
and so he called up a couple companies
he called up a few restaurants and just
decided that the number was 500 million
people gave him totally different
numbers and you know for daily use her
for yearly use or whatever and he just
kind of guessed and he actually admits
this too by the way he says quote why I
use this statistic is because it
illustrates that we use too many straws
I think if it were another number
it still illustrates the fact that there
is room for reduction that's really my
message this is Milo cress is a 16 year
old and this is this gives away the
whole story you know the left does this
all the time they make up some nonsense
and then could we conservatives find out
that what they've just said is nonsense
and they say well it's not true but it
gets to a greater truth no it's a lie
and it's a lie it's not it's not that
it's not true but it's a greater truth
it's a lie and then it's a lie so and
and Milo cress this kid says I don't
care if it's true it doesn't matter if
it's true the point is do what I say
right the point is do what we
environmentalists say and stop using the
straws so well you need to present to me
some kind no I don't need to do anything
do what I say we have too many we're
gonna get rid of them so I'm part of
this the plastic straw thing is that you
know there's this garbage patch in the
Pacific Ocean you might have read these
headlines there on a lot of clickbait
tea sites there's a huge floating island
of plastic bottles and you know refuse
that we don't recycle and it's floating
and it's taking over the whole ocean if
you looked at these pictures you would
believe that like half of the ocean of
the earth is just covered in plastic
bottles right it turns out that's just
completely not true so the island does
not exist it's nowhere and we know this
because they went to the heart of it
where the highest concentration of these
plastics are in the ocean they found
1,000 significant objects objects you
know like the size of this tumbler or
something objects you can actually see
with your eyes they found a thousand of
those over thousands of square miles so
you could have one of these for you know
10 square miles something like the eight
square miles totally ridiculous now you
might be saying
you couldn't be saying that I believe
you it's not that I don't believe you
but I've seen the pictures with my own
eyes
those pictures are just fake those
pictures are taken off the coast of
Manila in the Philippines that's taken
off the coast of other South Asian and
East Asian cities that are just dirty
that are just filled with trash
so it's true I could take a picture from
the dumpster downstairs I believe by my
200th episode that's where I'm going to
be a living I could go take a picture of
that and say you know isn't this dirty
and then try to pretend like it's the
Pacific Ocean but it's not it's just
totally made-up it does get to a really
important point with the left though
which is that they they could because
they control the narrative because they
control the culture they they put the
image in your head the image doesn't
have to be true the statistic doesn't
have to be true another example of this
as they say before roe v-- wade 5000
women a year died from back-alley
abortions now the guy who started saying
that he admitted he just made it up
they just plucked it out of thin air the
actual number was like 20 or 30 or
something the year before roe v-- wade
20 or 30 . 20 or 30 thousand 20 or 30
people but you get these images in your
head these numbers these pictures a
really great example of this this one
spread like wildfire last year is that
climate change is killing that polar
bear do you remember that polar bear
I'll show you the clip this was aired on
National Geographic it's been seen all
over the world I'll narrate it for those
of you who aren't watching here is that
poor polar bear starving because of
climate change you look so sad you can
barely walk says this is what a starving
polar bear looks like he's on his knees
now it can't find food where's the
what's all because of you because you
didn't recycle your plastic straws this
bear was spotted by National Geographic
photographer and Paul Nicklin on
Somerset island in the Canadian Arctic
I'm waiting for the Sarah McLachlan
music destroyed in
yeah andrew is now he's rummaging
through a trash can because of you
because you had to drive your Hummer cuz
you needed that SUV the bear went
missing after this footage was shot
making it impossible to know
specifically what ailed it oh that's
nice to sneak that in now however
scientists warn that its temperatures
rise in sea ice melts polar bears lose
access to the main staple of their diet
seals what about this poor seals at
least the seals get to live starving
running out of energy they're forced to
wander into human settlements looking
for food feeding polar bears to say
illegal without finding another source
of food this bear likely only had a few
hours to live this was this video it's
over a minute long it's spread like
wildfire
the title of it is this is what
starvation looks like it is estimated by
the photographer's and National
Geographic the two and a half billion
people saw this video in the images in
this video two and a half billion with a
B now the this was blasted out headlines
National Geographic this is what climate
change looks like they're saying climate
change is starving this polar bear right
finally these photographers and National
Geographic itself by the way are
admitting that this was a lie Mitter
mayer when the photographer says but
there was a problem we had lost control
of the narrative the first line of the
National Geographic video said this is
what climate change looks like with
climate change highlighted in the
brand's distinctive yellow in retrospect
National Geographic went too far and
what did Nat Geo say they said National
Geographic went too far in drawing a
definitive connection between climate
change and a particular starving polar
bear in the opening caption of our video
about the animal yeah duh animals can
starve in the wild that does happen the
plural of anecdote is not data and by
the way if this were caused by climate
change if we could say definitively this
is what climate change looks like we
would expect the polar bear population
to be plummeting isn't that right but
according to the 2016 scientific working
group right now on earth era between
twenty-two thousand six hundred and
thirty two thousand two hundred polar
bears that's up from 22,000 to thirty
one thousand in 2015
a year before that number was taken and
that's way up from an estimated 20 to 25
thousand in 2005
way up the despite what the climate
hysteria websites might tell you all of
the evidence points in the direction of
the polar bear population being way way
up and in fact estimates and from the
1960s said that at that time there were
between eight and ten thousand polar
bears
so obviously that population is doubled
if not tripled in in the intervening
5060 years now what the climate change
people will tell you is well we don't
know we just don't know we don't know
how many polar bears or stop saying the
polar bears are increasing and you say
well you've just given away the whole
story because you don't know right and
we can say at most that we don't know
how many polar bears there are but the
site the climate change people this the
environmentalists the environmental
hysterics they always act as though they
have such certainty right they say this
is what climate change looks like this
straw will destroy the planet this will
do if you do this it's going to lead it
but so frequently it doesn't it doesn't
mean anything it's just images designed
to pull on your heartstrings to
manipulate you to stop using your reason
to start supporting left-wing policies
that either will have no impact on the
environment or will hurt the environment
the the great example of this I love
this one it's it's almost enough to make
me get a Tesla and that's the electric
car the electric car that that's good
for the environment right we can at
least agree the electric car is good for
the environment right no it's terrible
for the environment
keep driving your Hummer baby my car I
Drive a v6 sedan it gets like 18 miles
to the gallon at best usually gets like
15 even better I'll try to I'll try to
rev it more so it only gets like 13 or
14 according to a study from the
University of Minnesota electric cars
are terrible for the environment this
was published in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Science it produces
more carbon emissions than conventional
cars and that's because of the batteries
the batteries are really awful for the
environment the co-author of that study
Julian Marshall who's an engineering
professor says it's kind of hard to beat
gasoline if you want to protect the
environment and people electric cars
produce 3.6 times as much soot in smog
death as gasoline cars it produces 80
percent more deaths from pollution and
the reason for this but I don't know if
you're confused about this the reason
why that is true is because electricity
doesn't come from magic you might think
that it comes from magic you know you go
you got your little electric car and you
get to drive in the fast lane in Los
Angeles and then you plug it in at night
and then unicorns jump up and down
joyfully and power your court that's not
what happens instead of unicorns on the
other end it's cold it's gold it's it's
not exclusively coal but it's largely
coal
39% of America's electricity is produced
by coal filthy dirty polluting coal how
about ethanol you might have what about
F ethanol is good isn't that good no not
at all
ethanol produces 80% more air pollution
mortality than gasoline vehicles also it
causes the price of corn to double or
triple which starves people in the third
world
good job environmentalists really nice
you're killing people with your
pollution and starving them in the third
world really nice the the only good one
and this is the ps/2 the resistance the
only way to make the electric cars work
and not be terrible for the environment
because there is a way there's a way to
make electric cars half is polluting as
gasoline vehicles much much better for
the environment do know how to do that
natural gas frack baby frack oh yes now
the environmentalist the one like really
good solution to all of this other than
nuclear which they also won't let us do
the other really good solution is
natural gas and they won't let us do it
because they spew out ridiculous
propaganda like gas land and tell us
that natural gas is poisoning our water
supplies here's just a little clip from
that ridiculous movie
I mean I thought I'd go for six give it
a sec
whoa oh wow look at that isn't it crazy
for those of you who couldn't see he
held his lighter underneath a faucet and
after a little while there was a puff of
fire you know from from the gas that
came in so the implication here is that
the fracking is poisoning our water
supply that's the allegation the only
trouble with that is that the Colorado
Department of Natural Resources
investigated this case and said there
are no indications of any oil and
gas-related impact to the well water it
what is true here as is true in a lot of
places where natural gas is prevalent is
that the natural gas in the water supply
comes from natural sources there was a
Duke study published on this also
published in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences showed that
there's higher methane in water wells in
the air gas wells that part's true
nobody's denying them the the issue here
though is it's caused by faulty steel
casing and cement ceiling on the wells
it's not caused by fracking it's also by
the way that water supply is not
contaminated by fracking fluids one
reason for that is that fracking fluids
are 99.5 percent water and sand it's
actually just fine how about for the air
is fracking terrible for the air no it's
not terrible for the air wrong wrong
again natural gas industry is
responsible for 2 percent of the
Pennsylvania smog causing volatile
organic compounds five percent of
nitrogen oxides and 1 percent of small
particulates emitted by all industry in
that state we could go on and on with
examples the the aspect here that
conservatives should really take away is
not you know not just the owning the
libs and the dancing and the spiking the
football all of which is great you
should totally do that too and it's not
just that whenever environmentalist says
something you should do the opposite
though that is also true what it what it
is is the limits of certainty the limits
of certainty in science the limits in
certainty of knowledge we don't really
know a lot of things and it takes a
great deal of Education to find out what
you don't know and I'm reminded of
Donald Rumsfeld he said there are no no
known unknowns and unknown unknowns
that's actually he got pilloried for
that he was made fun of but that's
actually a pretty sophisticated degree
of thinking we like certainty we like to
pretend that the expert in the white lab
coat is gonna give us all of the answers
to the world they don't know anything
they're much closer to shamans than they
are to gods they don't they don't know
for certain one thing I know about
science is that it's almost always not
true because they keep up ending
preconceptions and when you act as
though you have utter certainty about
the physical world about the material
world you're gonna get yourself into
trouble and so the Conservatives have a
kind of contrarian streak in them by
nature I think when these people are
telling you with certainty that in 200
years the world is going to explode
because you're using a sippy straw you
know you're using a plastic straw
instead of that sippy cup just just tell
them the other side of it show them the
other side of it it's really very
enjoyable because you know
environmentalism it's so clear but all
shallows are clear all shallow thinking
is very clear I've got to get to this as
America we're running a little late as
we always are I got to interview the
Griffin family they are it's
unbelievable I'll let them speak for
themselves but the the mother mrs.
Griffin was you know nine months
pregnant and a little a little early and
she went into a chick-fil-a bathroom to
use the bathroom and she ended up giving
birth to a child it this is the most
American story I've ever heard I think
I'm basically gonna have to shut my show
down after this because I can never get
anything more patriotic than the Griffin
story without further ado you're there
we have the Griffins thank you so much
for being here thank you and I'm really
honored because I know you haven't done
a ton of interviews but I saw this story
and just for people who haven't heard
all of the background you gave mrs.
Griffin you gave birth and mr. Griffin
you helped deliver your new daughter in
the bathroom of a chick-fil-a in Texas
you then swaddled the baby in your shirt
which was a trump 2020 shirt I have to
ask you is this the most American thing
that has ever happened in history we
were actually going to have a bald eagle
cut the cord that was
to find it really if fireworks went off
in the the cash registers in chick-fil-a
that will actually you bring up the the
umbilical cord and this is a really
incredible part of the story that hasn't
gotten a ton of attention which is that
there were a lot of potential
complications here to this birth mrs.
Griffin I believe you have epilepsy or
you suffer from epilepsy and and the the
baby was said to possibly have a heart
condition this was one of the worries
and the the umbilical cord was wrapped
around your daughter's neck is that
right that's right yeah that's
absolutely correct
in fact in in the delivery room all of
this was pre-planned for the birthing
plan because of the high risk of the
baby and the mom we were supposed to
have between eight to ten doctors in the
delivery room from neonatal specialist
to cardiologist to mean you name it
there was just supposed to be a wrongful
adopters not a bathroom stall with just
us so I do want to ask before I ask how
you were able to do this because I think
if this if this set of challenges were
presented to me there would be a Michael
shaped hole in the wall I would just run
screaming for dear life how did this
happen how did you end up in the
chick-fil-a okay so we live forty-five
miles from the hospital we live out in
hill country Texas so you know we try
and buy a lot of cattle ranches we don't
drive by a lot of hospitals in fact
there's not a hospital between us and
the hospital that we had to go to was
because of the high risk of both the
wife and the baby so we had to go to
that hospital the like I said all of
those specialists that were waiting for
us there earlier the day earlier in the
day we had gone to her 38 week checkup
his uh Graceland May was born two weeks
early to the day so earlier in the day
we went to her two-week checkup and her
doctor checked uh checked felon out and
said you know she's three centimeters
but she should be okay you know go home
relax take a bath have fun you know it's
maybe three days maybe seven days you
guys have time so you know what I did I
said honey can you take me to the nail
salon I'm gonna go get a pedicure I was
having contractions but they were
anything they were mildly mild and had
two babies before so I kind of knew what
was going on I knew they weren't Braxton
Hicks I knew they were you know it could
be any day now kind of thing but I when
I got to the nail salon I was like okay
no massaging just change the paint color
cuz I don't want you know to bring on my
labor I was you know really not wanting
her to come two weeks I'll even he said
I'm on a schedule here I only listen I
want to look good when grace LeMay
arrives but I don't you know you can sit
and the only reason we ended up at the
chick-fil-a Mia was one of our good
friends who is going to watch our older
girls for us when we actually went to
the hospital lives in the community
right behind that that shopping center
so we had called her and said hey we
don't have time to meet you at your
house just meet us in the parking lot at
chick-fil-a there's no signal light
there just jump right off the highway
drop the kids off in the parking lot
away we go
that was the plan so when we pulled into
that chick-fil-a a little bit after 20
minutes after 10:00 obviously they were
closed we knew what they were closed
yeah it must have looked like something
completely sketchy because we come
screeching in there right and ceiling of
the chick-fil-a and then there comes our
friend screech and right up next to us
we jump out of the car and putting kids
in her car if I was in the chick-fil-a
looking outside I probably would have
called my won-won then and said we're
about to get robbed there's some stuff
going on out front it was so sketchy
he's like banging on the door they
hadn't seen me yet so they're like who's
this guy I'm about to I'm about to have
a baby my wife's gonna give birth we've
heard that one before buddy all right
don't you try that one on us I really I
was a denial I really didn't think I was
gonna be giving birth oh I thought I had
to go to the bathroom I was like I think
we have time to stop it since
chick-fil-a's the only lighted place up
in this parking lot like let's see if
they'll let me in I have to go to use
the restroom that's the truth I swear to
you I said I really have to go please
let me in so then you go in I I assume
mr. Griffin that you did not join your
wife in the bathroom so you go into the
bathroom and then at what point do you
know that you're about to have a
daughter
oh sorry so I once they opened the door
for her which the chick-fil-a employees
yeah check this out the only reason why
they were even there is the the
employees at chick-fil-a they were just
waiting for their parents to come pick
them up so yeah after hearing all this I
was thinking maybe they're underage or
maybe they're not licensed alright looks
on their faces were like that is the
best birth control ever
we're abstaining from sex probably after
marriage to just it's over so so you're
you're in the bathroom you're you're
giving birth and what I want to know is
mr. Griffin you this is not an easy
birth I guess you've had a little bit of
practice with this before you've got a
couple kids were you terrified I mean I
would just be so uh in any in the best
of circumstances I would be sweating
bullets sweating blood probably in these
circumstances how did you keep it
together you know that's a good question
well I don't know how I kept together I
just kept thinking I thought I had to go
the bathroom
apparently something else is coming I
was like oh this is happening and so I
of course I'm screaming you know I'm in
excruciating pain and that's how I know
no I'm straddling the toilet I mean I
can't physically sit down my legs are
giving out on me I'm shaking
uncontrollably and I realized oh my gosh
this is happening there's a head coming
out of me and I know it's like a TMI but
it was like it was happening I scream
and Brenda the the lady working that
night
she's a drive-thru director her name's
Brendan Rica's to be exact she you know
was banning her crew you know they're
like like we said they they were closed
and so they were just finishing up the
job and she heard me screaming so she's
screaming for him he doesn't even know
his name just like hey your wife
screaming in there buddy yeah
yeah I just put that just the kids
goodnight and tried to call him down a
little bit cuz they were a little
concerned I said you know you know kiss
them goodnight your guys are gonna be
fine and then as I was walking back to
the chick-fil-a I heard Brenda scream
your wife's in the bathroom and she's
screaming so I run in there and she had
locked the door so we got the door
locked and I wanna I open it up and
she's in the first stall which is the
tiniest of them all it's made for one
definitely not made for two and no baby
to clear the record straight I did not
choose the handicap stall because I did
not have time something what's gonna
give I didn't know what it was I just
thought it's very very polite of you you
think well I'm not handicapped I don't
really need it what if somebody else
needs a tell you I'll use the small one
it's exactly right it's exactly
intuition there so all I could do was
wedge between the toilet and the back
wall of the stall and get into that back
little corner there and you know kind of
assess what was going on and I could
just see the head crowning and my wife
was standing and I told her honey we're
gonna do something great but we're gonna
do it right here we're gonna do it right
now
so she put one hand on the side wall and
first the key for that I was holding her
in because my biggest fear was trucking
her in the toilet right and I I had my
my water had broken the moment he
literally like opened the door jammed in
and so there was just no time for error
he like he said he came in he wedged
himself back there and he was it was the
quarterback I told her I said you know
you are the CEO you're the manufacturer
you're the you do the whole I just ran
your shipping and receiving that's all I
did
Willie is Hren it is really amazing to
consider the the mental states of both
of you at this point because mr. Griffin
on the one hand you were there you're
thinking I look I'm the one who's not
physically incapacitated I've got to
kind of manage this control this you
know make sure that the umbilical cord
isn't gonna remain wrapped around or
whatever but then mrs. Griffin you are
in the world basically the worst of
circumstances to be doing this and and
no drugs whatsoever nope no pain
medication at all you are just going for
it that's great not even a bed I mean it
me so she delivered standing up oh my
god do you get a Medal of Honor for that
or something that is under you know
we've all had to suffer through the
World Cup over the past few weeks the
least athletic pseudo sport in history
meanwhile you're doing the most athletic
feat ever to be done you know you're up
there like tap dancing while giving
birth really unbelievable so you do this
and the and the baby's fine there's no
worry of you know the the umbilical cord
or anything like that how did you manage
that so what happened was as soon as I
saw that the head was crowning that's
when I yelled to whoever could hear
because there were no chick-fil-a
employees in the bathroom and I wasn't
looking for him I just shouted somebody
call 9-1-1 and bring me towels or clean
something clean whatever you've got and
the like I said the the head stopped her
at the shoulders because I could tell
that the cord was wrapped around her
neck twice and the baby's face was blue
so unwrap the cord twice and then told
Fallon hey we've got I need two really
good pushes we've got to get her out of
here right now so she pushed on and she
came out and at a stall bathroom door
he's behind me so I didn't want to alarm
her that the cord was wrapped around her
neck because one of the big concerns
with this pregnancy in this delivery was
because of the epilepsy yep lowering her
threshold of having a seizure was a real
danger of course I didn't want to put
into extra stress on her saying hey the
cords wrapped around I just told her hey
relax for a minute there's something I
got to do and got that down and just
told her to push and wrapped her up in
my Trump shirt which was highly
appropriate and and that's all I had at
that time when she should when she did
come out I had two paper towels and my
Trump shirt and that's how I dried off
Gracie is with that and then the
chick-fil-a representative Bren
came back in with 911 on the phone and
she was gonna hand me the phone one you
you've got to put him on speaker I'm
here to relay messages phone please
okay so she did and so I was asking
questions about you know her being blue
I knew it was one of two things either
oxygen levels were low or she was cold
and all I had was wet things but really
quickly after that
chick-fil-a started bringing in some of
the towels that they had and let me tell
you something if you don't think that
there was divine intervention in this
whole thing I'll just give you one
little snippet those towels that they
brought in I was asking for warm towels
and they brought them to me and they
were brand-new white towels about the
size of a kitchen towel terry cloth that
were warm and i would i thought wow
that's awesome they were microwaving I'm
putting mitt whatever they were doing
how resourceful was it it turns out that
Brenda knew that in there one of their
storage rooms was brand new towels and
just happened that that day the air
conditioning went out in that room only
so she went in there and there were nice
warm towels because it was 104 degrees
that day in San Antonio they didn't
microwave them they didn't cook them or
anything they were now they were a nice
warm towel sitting there wrapped in
plastic she just opened him up and
brought him to us you know that I I'm a
big believer in Providence I you can see
these sort of things all the time and it
is amazing I always think that God
sometimes you know he'll whisper and
you'll say hey Michael hey you know and
then of course we don't ever notice so
he says hey dummy come on look I'm right
here and you know so you have the in the
chick-fil-a this mutton is American
institution
you've got the Trump shirt you know
self-reliance delivering yourself and
then this woman and I'm praying that
everything behind me is going well
because I sure as heck don't know how to
deliver a baby by myself I'm like oh
dude I hope this guy knows what he's
doing
why did he know I know in all
seriousness I was praying and I just
said please like please Lord give my
husband wisdom and patience and strength
and I was just praying for everything
and just of course praying for this baby
too and good answer yeah exactly I
wanted her to cry because I didn't hear
her cry right away so I knew something
was up when she wasn't crying oh you did
so that that was the kind of hint you
couldn't good
something like you're wrong wow I was
trying to stay calm and because again
the seizure was definitely a concern of
mine and we needed just to be a good
team and so I just know I just need to
hang in there and it was it was a rough
it was a rough few minutes but actually
about ten minutes before the EMTs game
yeah EMS didn't show up to about seven
to 10 minutes after unbelievable you
know I tell my time I could not sit down
because then built rapport the placenta
is still attached to me and so if I had
moved one inch in any direction it would
pull it from her belly from her belly
button oh my god she comes over and I'm
hunched over into my body is my nerves
are shot and I have to tell you my my
nerves are shot just listening to this
story yeah I'm at the edge of my seat
even though I know it has a happy ending
I picture I haven't had my first child
yet and I've always pictured sort of
like a pacing around the waiting room
and like a blazer chain-smoking reading
the newspaper and this is exactly the
opposite of that but it you know that
your daughter's name is Graceland May
aptly named clearly grace abounds here
this is this is just an incredible story
I mean this is America in a nutshell and
I'm so pleased for all of you have to
let you go but I'm so pleased that
everything worked out as miraculously as
it did and and you now have a lifetime
supply of chick-fil-a and a job for your
daughter when she turns 16 it just keeps
getting better I don't know what the
best part of that story is it's someone
I've gotta let you go but I I do always
I sometimes joke with my wife we say you
know gosh I really really hope that our
baby is cute I really hope our first
baby is cute and you you clearly lucked
out even on that front even on that
front grace abounds unbelievable story
thank you so much for coming on the
Griffins
I can't I can't wait to I'll check back
in in 16 years when when your daughter
gets her job at chick-fil-a all right
thank you
see you guys this is America that is
very America if only the bald eagle came
down and clipped the umbilical cord with
its talons so I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube we've got a lot
more to get to I do want to talk about
this election a little bit I want to
talk about the celebrities who are gonna
be jumping in and probably destroying
Democrats chances again just like they
did in 2016 and also the new Republican
challenger who is now suggesting he will
primary Donald Trump in 2020 we'll see
how that goes
if you're on Facebook and YouTube go to
daily wire.com it is ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you help
keep the lights on if you're already
there thank you very much
look none of it matters the conversation
the mailbag get your mailbag questions
in right I mean whatever this is what
matters this is what matters I'm going
to DC in about twenty minutes i'm going
down to give a speech at ya young
America's Foundation and I'm gonna be
talking about the great benefits of
owning the lives a robust defense of
owning the lives and you're gonna need
this tumbler because otherwise the whole
District of Columbia is gonna flood and
you're gonna drown don't drown make sure
you get your leftist ears tumblr and
make sure you get extra plastic on it
just all over the place movies if you
have if you have an old leftist here's
tumblr just toss it in the pacific ocean
to get a new one sign up again go to
daily wires hot gum we'll be right back
okay the elections back on all the
celebrities are coming out in force to
stump for Democrats just like they did
in 2016 whomp-whomp here is a new public
service announcement from the voice of
the American people Vox Populi Jane
Fonda and Lily Tomlin hi I'm Jane Fonda
I'm Lily Tomlin I'm rashida Jones do you
care about gun control women's health
income inequality the environment health
care and I call my dentist back I've
already six months late on my annual
cleaning Rasheeda oh no is that a
toothache Rasheeda
come on this is important you're right
yeah I know our democracies at stake I'm
sorry I do have a great dentist by the
way I'll give you her number one we're
done are you hearing my thoughts it's
not important just get back to your
lines please uh voter turnout during
midterms is historically terrible with
nearly half the voters compared to years
with presidential elections and that's
just not gonna work this November Wow I
can't believe we're sure I need to
protect basic human rights and the
planet I'm exhausted
you're exhausted I've been fighting for
six decades oh my god I get people to
volunteer to make sure other people vote
thinking we got lied down somewhere
maybe with a beach there be good Lily
Tomlin's trying to save the planet is
she is she just using like five plastic
straws at a time while driving her
Hummer around I didn't this this has
taken a turn that I didn't expect
is this a Hummer ad that's great so
absurd I mean really really ridiculous I
hope they keep doing this I counted up
on the Wikipedia page last night at the
Hillary Clinton 2016 presidential race I
believe the number is 1868 celebrities
athletes actors directors musicians
endorsed Hillary Clinton in 2016 nobody
cares nobody cares for a few reasons one
because we have other things on our mind
and two there isn't there's not a
celebrity disparity anymore we have
one of the biggest Hollywood celebrities
not only stumping for us but he's
actually our president we have him in
the White House and it totally mixes
that also Hollywood looks awful with all
this meat to stuff you know I people
look really morally decrepit and they
haven't turned out good product in a
long time other than Mission Impossible
3 when Tom Cruise tells me to vote for
somebody I'll probably vote for that
person but all of these other people
I don't why would I listen to Jane Fonda
Jane Fonda's a traitor to our country
who post on anti-aircraft for the
Vietnamese Hanoi Jane who cares what
they have to say that is not a big issue
in other celebrity 20/20 news LeBron
James is suggesting that he's going to
run for office now you know we're just
in the throws of silly season when all
of this happens the dog days of summer
the one story worth mentioning though
because I suppose it could be real it's
also ridiculous is being reported by the
Daily Caller which is that Bill Kristol
the former editor are now editor at
large of the Weekly Standard a bill
kristol
considered neoconservative Straus Ian's
magazine editor very anti Trump is
considering primary endowment Trump in
2020 I like Bill Kristol very much I
should get this out of the way i bill
kristol was a professor of mine during a
summer fellowship that I had
he's been very nice I listened to his
podcast conversations with Bill Kristol
I actually like the guy even though he's
really going off the rails with this
never Trump and anti Trump stuff but he
should not run for president in 2020 it
will not help him it will not help the
Republican Party it will not help the
conservative movement it will just look
really really foolish and frivolous oh
he said this he said this to the New
York Times in 2017 Bill Kristol said we
need to take one shot at liberating the
Republican Party from Trump and
conservatism from trumpism and here's my
question for mr. Kristol why why do why
do we have to do that we've gotten
historic tax reform excellent judges
federal judges and Supreme Court
justices a piece abroad we're really
strong foreign policy good foreign
policy a booming economy
we've gotten record-low joblessness
we've got--we've the issues that
Democrats usually harp on racial
division we've kind of wiped those out
because not only are we winning in the
popular culture but we're also winning a
historically low black unemployment a
hate crimes are down I think all crime
is a crime but hate crime as we define
it is down everything is going so well
that doesn't even scratch the surface
why why do we need to liberate the
Republican Party from trump is it
because the years of george w bush were
so much better for conservative
governance I'm not attacking President
Bush but is that really the height of
conservatism I don't think it was
Medicare Part D the height of
conservatism No Child Left Behind was
that the height of conservatism Harriet
Miers even John Roberts was that great
conservative governance I don't know
about that Oh George Bush Senior is that
the raising taxes is that the height I
don't what why on earth would we
liberate the Republican Party from Trump
in conservatism from trumpism I
understand the skepticism of President
Trump in 2016 but he's done a very good
job
you know we laugh about LeBron James
running for office or Oprah or whatever
and they say well it's hypocritical
Michael we're in the age of the
celebrity Donald Trump isn't qualified
to be President and I agree with that in
2016 but now he is he he clearly was
qualified to be President he's been a
very good president we you can't say
well now we're just electing celebrities
who are unqualified no no that could
have been the case had Trump in a bad
president but he's been good so I don't
understand that I think it's really
navel-gazing it's really ideological
really frivolous really silly according
to the Daily Caller
mr. Kristol is in Boston now he's
meeting with New Hampshire political
strategists he went to a New Hampshire
political event it's really not a good
idea I really do like what mr. Kristol
offers to the conservative movement I
recommend listening to some of his
podcast even though they need to fix the
audio on it the audio is not great but
the show is really quite interesting but
the this is absurd what what are we
fighting for we are we fighting one
another over how best to hold our tea
cup or how to comport ourselves at
cocktail parties in Georgetown is that
what we're doing are we fighting for
Liberty because if it's if it's the
former
than fine attack Trump all you want if
it's the latter get your priorities
straight what are you doing what are you
people doing because there are there are
real issues that are being fought rich
Lowry from National Review has an
excellent column out about how the
United States is now debating socialism
we are seriously considering socialism
you can say crazy-eyed Alexandria oh
Casio Cortez she's not a serious
candidate she's not taken over the party
you know there there are 42 candidates
running with the Democratic socialists
endorsement in in 2018 this is growing
Bernie Sanders has really opened this up
he's brought this medicare-for-all
socialist medicine canard
he's made it mainstream and socialism is
slavery healthcare is the place that
they tried to do it most a President
Reagan before he was president when he
was still just a terrific b-movie actor
in Hollywood he had a great album about
the evils of socialist medicine need to
be fighting that we don't need to be
fighting over how to hold our Shepley
glasses we need to fight this real
battle because it's it's coming and it's
evil and it could really destroy the
country here for those of you who
haven't heard it is Ronald Reagan
talking about the evils of socialist
medicine my name is Ronald Reagan I have
been asked to talk on several subjects
that have to do with the problems of the
day now back in 1927 an American
socialist Norman Thomas six times
candidate for president and the
Socialist Party ticket said the American
people would never vote for socialism
but he said under the name of liberalism
the American people will adopt every
fragment of the socialist program there
are many ways in which our government
has invaded the precincts of private
citizens the method of earning a living
one of the traditional methods of
imposing statism or socialism on a
people has been by way of Medicine it's
very easy to disguise a medical program
as a humanitarian project most people
are a little reluctant to oppose
anything that suggests medical care for
people who possibly can't afford it now
in our country under our free enterprise
system we have seen medicine reach the
greatest heights that it has in any
country in the world today
the relationship between patient and
doctor in this country is something to
be envied any place the privacy the care
that is given to a person the right to
choose a doctor the right to go from one
doctor to the other the right to choose
the the quality of the care the the
prosperity that engenders and that it
symbolizes you should listen to the
whole thing the whole album is ten or
eleven minutes you can find it all over
YouTube go listen to it it's very
important
socialism is slavery the way they try to
institute it they get it in by the
backdoor on health care because they
think people won't act rationally on
health care
they'll just that they won't be willing
to point out the advantages of freedom
in health care because it's so immediate
it's so emotional don't let them do it
the government that's big enough to give
you everything you want is big enough to
take away everything you've got
healthcare is the key here if you if you
have looked at no other news story in
the last couple of years look at little
baby Alfie Evans or little baby Charlie
guard in the UK babies who their parents
wanted them to get treatment elsewhere
but the socialist government in the UK
I'm not talking about Venezuela I'm
talking about the developed world the
United Kingdom would not let those
babies seek treatment in in the United
States or in Rome or anywhere else they
said this baby is gonna stay here we own
this baby the baby's gonna die deal with
it the government that is big enough to
give you everything you want it's big
enough to own you big enough to take
away everything you've got you got to
fight it tooth and nail Medicare for all
it's slavery and get your priorities in
order people don't get angry because
President Trump doesn't spell all of his
tweets correctly or he uses random
capitalization there's a really evil
evil ideology that is rearing its ugly
crazy-eyed batty head and we've got to
fight it very seriously
I'm going to DC I'm getting out of here
I will not see you tomorrow but I'll be
back Thursday and Friday get your mail
bad questions then we're doing it
Thursday if you're in DC or if you're at
the aft conference I'll see you there in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show I'll see you
soon
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Jim nickel audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the Michael Knowles show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018